he's becoming a brand people see him on
get up as a matter of fact he's I see
him on get up when Rex Ryan's running
his mouth his name is Pat McAfee here on
the Rich Eisen show how are you Patrick
weird some fantastic that intro just you
know tickled me in all the right places
I can't thank you enough for allowing me
a little time on the air you always have
a spot here you know that Pat you know
that sir did I miss anything you've got
a podcast to write the Pat McAfee show
2.0 you've got that one working as well
yeah there's too much of me right now
rich I think even my mom's about sick of
me but I am having quite a fall we also
obviously have a small business over
here in Indianapolis where we sell some
merch and I do a little bit of stuff
with the WWE a lot of people are
questioning whether or not I'm going to
survive through December we'll see I'm
really testing the limit of humans at
this moment but it's been a fun fall
that's far rich Pat it's a marathon not
a sprint and you're a marathon runner I
know that deep down inside deep down
inside strip away the punting and the
kicking and the comedy and and all that
you're you've got the heart of a
marathon or you got it you've got this
thing just a way rich I'm a sprinter in
every aspect of life drinking kicking
you name it I am a sprinter but let's
hope the marathon thing really adapts to
me now that I'm 32 and getting older I
mean I hope it happens I've told you
this bad I've told you this off off air
I'll say it here again on the air you
just be keep being you and your your
your gonna be just fine and here's a
perfect example because this is you this
was a total you when Rex Ryan went down
went down the path on the Cleveland
Browns on get up the other day and your
reaction was what we call priceless
Jarvis Landry Nick Chubb and in this
Baker Mayfield yeah I know he's
overrated as hell but here's the only
other Wow this team knows you have no
tackles I know you went double whoa Pat
you went double low there yeah listen I
respect the hell out of Rex Ryan I think
since he's gotten on TV too his teeth
are fantastic he's got a magnetic pan I
like the fact that Rex Ryan's family is
one of the greatest football families in
the history of football I respect
everything he says but man that shot at
old Baker Mayfield came out of left
field and I just couldn't help myself I
mean obviously I have no couth in the
booth people know that that's why the
NFL refused to let me call any games
this year very thankful that he has be
ended
but in those studio shows I don't know
what I'm supposed to talking when I'm
not supposed to talk and I just couldn't
let it happen like whoa wait a minute
Rex Ryan let's not be burying a guy just
because he shot guns beers at baseball
games and he drives around on power
recliners with Stone Cold Steve Austin
and he's already in commercials in all
this I don't think we can call guy
overrated yet he's only 17 games into
this thing I and it blew my mind and now
it's a talking point throughout the
entire week I could have never guessed
it it just I was mind blowing I was
baffled rich and that was just a very
natural reaction listening to my brain
still right out of my mouth when I
probably wasn't supposed to talk no but
yeah I think most people had that
reaction because no one was calling him
overrated last year and he's still the
same guy the question is is what is up
with the Browns Pat but do you have a
theory on that subject well I think it's
one of those things where you get new
weapons you get new toys there's a new
head coach ok and if Freddie kitchens
has been around Baker since the
beginning drew stint and also a veteran
backup quarterback has been in that
offensive meeting room and quarterback
room helping out with the play designs
and play calls but I think there are
still a lot of feeling out period and
the thing with Freddie kitchens is
whenever you get somebody like Odell
Beckham on your team you feel obligated
to try and make it happen for him and I
think he comes from that Bruce Arians
offensive mind and I get a chance to
watch this with Andrew Luck whenever he
was young it's a big time no risk it no
biscuit type operation
you're gonna have your quarterback sit
back though there's gonna be a lot of
route 10 plus yards down the field so
you kind of got to let them happen and
let the place happen it's something that
can pop off deep but if you don't have
an offensive line and granted there's no
offensive line that can really stop
Aaron Don what I mean the guy is just
say genetic freak in a monster but if
your quarterback starts feeling the
pressure
but you're gonna dip out of those place
you don't get your ass kicked on
national television
and I think right now they're still
trying to feel it out they're still
trying to figure it out fourth of nine
draw call definitely suspect I think
everybody would argue that but I think
Baker's a big time momentum guy a
big-time mojo guy and I think once they
hit it think they have a real chance but
the overrated comment for me was just
like hey what 17 games into this thing I
think Peyton Manning had no less than
150 interceptions in his first 17 games
and he turned out to be pretty good and
so that was my reaction to that but I
think the Browns have a chance to turn
things around and I also enjoy in like
the fact that Odell Beckham jr. for
everything that's ever happened to him
and been said about him from proposing
to kick in next all the other stuff that
happens off the field he had the chance
there to really turn into a prima donna
after that I mean I think a lot of
people would expect that whenever you're
only targeted one time in the last four
series of a very close game
not targeted at all in first and goal
situation and instead he took the high
road I think they really believe in
themselves over there I think they just
need to get a little bit of momentum get
a little mojo find a rhythm and I think
whatever that happens they're going to
be ok but you got to remember this
franchise they couldn't even drink Bud
Light for the last two years and is ever
locked up until they got a win Baker's
the 101 lock tattoo Pat McAfee and you
know the issue is for the Browns is this
is not the week to get back on it I mean
they're gonna go into Baltimore and I
think they're gonna get thumped I really
believe that I love the Ravens and the
Ravens last week went ahead into Kansas
City and was going forward on on for
two-point conversions like it was going
out of style there there were analytics
there their heads off and they just you
know God got my homes I mean I think a
lot of people are finding out they're
gonna get in the homes and now the
Ravens are gonna perhaps hand it to the
Browns that's my my prediction for this
weekend you know I don't think that's
gonna happen if they're passing the ball
43 times though with Lamar and I enjoyed
listening to Lamar Jackson talk about
how he hates running and I think that's
a smart move by the way because history
tells us that quarterbacks that are a
lot of running normally don't last long
I enjoyed watching the mark
the first couple weeks he passed the
ball 20 ball 20 times the first week had
a perfect passer rating everybody was
like wait a minute is running back has
become a precision passer then the next
week he fasted 37 times in his last week
43 times because they thought they had
to keep up with the homes I think Lamar
Jackson and Greg Roman are still trying
to figure out what all they can do and
what they can't do but I like that
Ravens team I like the defense
I like the toughness in the attitude not
only of the organization but the city I
think that's going to be a very tough
game but that's another AFC North game
now that's a big time game for the
Browns I wouldn't rule them out of it I
think they have a chance but I do like
what the Ravens have been doing as well
Pat McAfee here on the Rich Eisen show
which which which team three no two and
one is most Fugazi what do you think one
that you you're like you don't buy it
just yet they just off to a good start
what do you got for me so we have two
undefeated games going on you know this
weekend and I think the Chiefs and Pats
are going to be tough to stop regardless
but I like that the bills and liens now
granted
tie game is one of the most embarrassing
things to happen in American history I
think anybody that was a part of that
game would tell you that in in our sport
but I think I asked the question on my
show which team is more likely to get
the home upset that are both home dogs
Oh buffalo bills or the Detroit Lions
what do you got for me man I and I
believe and even more so now after last
night Tom Brady liked a video from the
NFL Network saying that the bills are
going to get the upset by the Patriots
so Tom Brady strides off to that type of
stuff if somebody said something bad
about him he's going to target them Tom
Brady is just this guy who forever has
been building this legacy now it's like
he's on a victory lap and it seems like
it's never going to end
somehow they lose Gronk Tom turned 60
and they've gotten even better their
defense is unstoppable so I don't think
the Bills have any shot against the
Patriots that's actually one of my locks
is the Patriots - 7 and a half but I
think the Lions can keep it close with
the Chiefs strictly because I like what
Matt Latricia has built in the culture
that has been being built inside of the
Lions locker room last year there was a
lot of conversation law comes to
Matt Latricia has lost the locker room
Matt Patricia can't rally the troops
mattress or what broke his ankle towards
Achilles whatever the hell it was not on
the quad this offseason now he's rolling
around on a little scooter singing and
that team seems to be believing up yeah
Matty staff has been protected I think
they have a chance to keep it close but
for me I think the Buffalo Bills are the
team that I love watching their fans
perform before games I like watching
them have a little bit of success I like
the thought of dildos getting tossed on
the field but for me I think the Buffalo
Bills are about to turn and do a little
bit of a downfall and it's going to
start with palm Brady and handsome
Julian Edelman I think Pat McAfee giving
us his picks including all the
intangibles here on the Rich Eisen show
Pat McAfee sure so you said this on the
Pat McAfee show or the Pat McAfee show
2.0 or on get up I don't I can't I can't
figure I can't follow it anymore Pat
your Bureau you're branding here it's
it's all for the brand I don't even know
what the brand is anymore there's so
many breaks which I did yeah the brand
is kickers and punters there are things
that are boy for the brand in bad for
the rent right my particular brand now
that I have all these different avenues
of content the live show is much
different than the podcast podcast a lot
longer conversation something that
you're incredible at something that I
try to bring out the best of my guests
and the live shows a lot of polls a lot
of picks a lot of hot takes and then
when I get on get up I just try to put
makeup on be on the mothership not swear
let it loose and say some things that
will hopefully drive some conversation
so there's different avenues they're
different they're meant for different
things but they are all kind of just
blending together at this point yeah I
gotta be careful then when to work blue
when you're not just don't forget where
you're on you know what I mean like
because you're working blue on your pod
but definitely not on Westwood one right
and then definitely not on ESPN
I assume you guys learned this in like
journalism school and stuff like that
yeah whenever I sit down and I get miked
up I have to have a fool like 45 seconds
to a minute long conversation about
where I'm at yep who's potentially
listening and when I'm on ESPN I just
think of Mickey Mouse and Woody and Buzz
and everybody at Disney I'd be listening
and hopefully I just turn off the switch
for the swear words I don't embarrass my
mom and then whenever I get on the
podcast it's like all right what all of
them out get it all out now because
every other time you're on a mic there's
a potential FCC find ready to take down
your entire company hear that you have
that ability to go on one's case to
infinity and beyond and then understand
where you are otherwise Pat because I
have worked with many folks before many
former athletes turned broadcasters like
yourself who can't put two words
together on ESPN I remember at ESPN I
want to call his name out right now but
his former NBA player who in the
meetings was great just lit up with all
sorts of information and energy but was
cursing his head off the entire time
when he had to remove the curse words
from his commentary couldn't put two
words together and and and didn't pan
out so I'm glad to know that you have
that gear switch Pat Leary so back when
I was on bar stool with bar stools yeah
and I was able to just do whatever I
wanted on seriously there's no rules but
the WWE they asked me if I wanted to
come do some stuff with them and they've
become a super PG operation like I don't
really think you can say half there so
for the two weeks leading up to the WWE
show I said alright I'm gonna have a
swear jar for every single time I swear
I'm gonna put a hundred bucks in there
for every time I swear for the next two
weeks and we ended up donating it to
this kid named Jason Wheatley who was
muscular dystrophy is something that
he's bedridden basically one is we
wanted to upgrade his room so he put the
swear jar together two weeks it'll end
up being $13,000 which offers 100% sure
all for a good cause man yeah yeah you
just got to be careful you can say that
a word you just can't have a preposition
before it that's all that's that's
that's and you used what word did you
use last night during your
broadcast even tweeted it out Pat like
incredulous or what what word did you
drop during the broadcast last night
there's like at least three or four
syllables I was very impressed by that
rich thank you West Virginia University
graduate but I was there and I knew
yesterday with the triple option that
Navy run yes we're gonna hammer home
just that the quarterback has to make
decisions quickly right so I knew I was
gonna have to say it people don't love
my voice but they especially don't love
my voice if I'm saying the same thing
over and over again right so I asked my
smart friends that I have I'm like hey I
need other words for quickly in the
first one they sent over was impetuous
that's the one in Petula's yes and I got
it in there early to be honest I was
pretty excited about it but I've never
been more nervous to deliver something
because those Navy folks are watching
that game really smart group of humans I
was just trying to keep up with them but
it made me feel good I'm the Auris my
mom is proud there's a big moment for
our family to get that word out there I
know you are a little bit too impetuous
and dropping the word Pat see what I
learned right there see I'm just trying
to go next level that's all I'm trying
to do brothers I did hey did you hear I
said that and nobody said anything I had
to compliment myself using your social
media platforms that just blow up at Pat
McAfee show on Twitter and Instagram you
can follow Pat show on Twitter at Pat
McAfee on to zone D AZN you got to spell
that out since it's you know how many
people say man I love you on dasn't did
they say that to you Pat do they say
that to you PR problem currently a lot
of people say Dave's in a lot of people
say Kazon but it is the zone and
whenever I'm in a zone and I'm speaking
big old words the zone can only grow
from that but yeah I think right now a
big part of this is awareness on how to
hel to pronounce the global number one
app to zone which I'm very lucky to be a
part of okay before I let you go Chris
Brockman you just came up with a parting
question for Pat McAfee before he goes
this is a good one I like it go for
Chris yeah Pat it was announced
yesterday JLo and Shakira
halftime act of the Super Bowl any
initial thoughts your your thoughts ah
listen don't be fooled by the rocks that
I got I'm still I'm still Jenny from the
block and the block that Jenny is from
just is New York in the block that
Shakira is from is Columbia and Adam
Schefter tweeted that this is Super Bowl
in Miami we add a little Miami flavor I
thought he was going to get ruined for
that by you know the mob on the internet
I thought he was going to get it but I
absolutely love the thought of JLo and
Shakira their hips don't lie they're
incredibly talented and if mr. 305
pitbull doesn't make an appearance
I will boycott the second half of the
Super Bowl but I am pumped up about it I
always enjoy those Super Bowl halftime
content or performances because half the
people are going to hate it half the
people are gonna love it and I'm just
there to sit back and watch the internet
explode regardless of what happens yeah
I know that the the block from which
both these wonderfully talented
performers are from not not Miami but
that's fine that's fine we're good and
as long as they just put on a good show
and you're right that would be a major
upset if pitbull does not appear major
upset huge I would agree mr. worldwide -
I mean Superbowl is a worldwide
operation you don't drink mr. worldwide
in its hometown
what are you doing maybe we get Ricky
Ross in there to trick daddy I mean if
we're gonna go through the entire thing
wasn't they mark Paul or whatever the
guy I used to be married to JLo I mean
let's just get it all out there let's
make sure that Miami was being
broadcasted well and let's go ahead and
put on a hell of a show for the
Superbowl I agree if we're good just get
Gloria Estefan and the Miami Sound
Machine let's just go let's go Don John
I'm just going way back I hid the way
back button on your pad Miami Sound
Machine yeah don't worry well the game
is not just for young folks you have no
idea really listening you have no idea
how the rhythms gonna get your pad just
keep just keep on out out there just I'm
gonna I'm gonna stop making these
references because they're cold totally
going over your head
but in the meantime what I'm greatly
appreciative you being on this program
rich you got to remember and you've
talked to me enough you know this like a
lot of references just go wait up I have
become in a week talent yet back thing
is if I know exactly what we're talking
about pivoting whoa because I know no
clue Pat you are the best keep it up
brother I'm really really excited to
watch you on on ESPN and everything else
that you're doing to zone your podcast
your your WWE the whole bit
take care of yourself let's let's keep
talking hey rich you're the best man
tell Chris I said hello - I hope you
guys know he is not he is covering the
the fight that's going on this week
that's important Benson Porter coming up
this week and he is way too important
he's laying wires and making sure it
sounded like it what if you hear if you
hear the touching of gloves or the
gloves touching somebody else's face or
or hear the body shots it's because Mike
has done his job or at least tells us
that's what he's doing
well Chris and rich when I say this I
mean this it sucks to suck boys tell to
close the star of that show take care
yourself at anybody hey thank you guys
that we can cheers you too brother
that's Pat McAfee America's Sweetheart
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app